Who doesn’t love dogs?
They’re friendly, energetic, and can be
beneficial to their owners’ happiness and
mental health.
On top of all those positive qualities, most
dogs are fiercely loyal to their masters.
You’ll often hear stories of dogs defending
their owners, or even staying by their side
through their very last days and even sticking
next to them beyond death.
As sad as that thought might be to many dog
owners, it provides us the perfect context
for today’s topic.
It’s about time that you met SCP-1111.
Sometimes also known by the nickname “The
White Dog”, this moniker actually refers
to one of the two halves of SCP-1111, namely
the former: SCP-1111-1, while its counterpart
is simply known only as SCP-1111-2.
As you may have already deduced, SCP-1111-1
is, or at least appears to be, a fairly common
domesticated dog.
Sporting white fur that gives it its nickname,
the White Dog is a cross between two different
popular breeds, the German Shepherd and the
Labrador Retriever.
However, upon closer inspection, this particular
pup is a far cry from one you might see fetching
sticks or chasing squirrels at the park.
For one, this dog never eats or drinks.
Under normal circumstances, that would be
worrying behavior in any dog, but in SCP-1111-1’s
case, it comes second to the fact that this
dog is partially see-through.
Now that’s definitely not normal, in actual
fact this pooch is pretty far from ordinary.
It seems to be at least semi-translucent,
not quite as much as we usually picture a
ghost or a hologram, but also not fully visible
like a living being.
In fact, how clearly visible the White Dog
is can vary depending on how close it is to
1111-2.
Any further than five hundred meters away,
and the dog will gradually grow more and more
transparent, but not fully invisible.
But visibility isn’t the only thing that
shifts with 1111-1’s distance from its other
half, the size of the dog also changes.
It remains standing at 150 centimeters when
directly beneath 1111-2 and gradually gets
smaller the further and further away from
1111-2 it gets.
Finally, there’s its eyes.
SCP-1111-1 possesses a distinct pair of glowing
red eyes, the brightness and intensity of
which increase the closer it is to 1111-2.
So let’s recap: so far we have a strange
white dog with glowing eyes, that changes
size and becomes more or less visible the
further it gets from a secondary element.
But, if the White Dog is SCP-1111-1, then
what forms this second part of SCP-1111?
Well, if you were to look close enough at
the white dog, you’d notice the red collar
that it wears around its neck.
And hanging from that collar is a tag, on
which is printed one single word: “Loyal.”
It’s certainly a fitting word to describe
1111-1.
Why?
Because SCP-1111-2 is presumably the dog’s
master - or rather, its master’s dead body.
Dressed in an old, worn business suit and
formal dress shoes, SCP-1111-2 appears to
be a deceased male of indeterminate age.
The precise identity of this man has proven
next to impossible for Foundation researchers
to determine.
The condition of his suit and shoes have deteriorated
so much that it has been difficult to even
identify the original company that produced
the clothing worn by the corpse.
As for his cause of death?
Well, that unfortunately seems all too obvious,
given that the 1111-2 body always appears
the same way: hanging from a tree with a noose
around his neck.
Foundation staff observing the two parts that
make up SCP-1111 have noted that 1111-2 will
occasionally make quick, violent twitching
movements.
These random jerks and spasms of the corpse
are consistent with those exhibited by a person
who is dying from asphyxiation, and often
researchers have heard the body making desperate
gasps for air.
The closer his white furred canine counterpart
is, the more frequent and violent these motions
and sounds will become.
It’s almost as if SCP-1111-2 has somehow
been trapped on the very brink of death, reliving
those final moments over and over again, all
while guarded by his loyal White Dog.
If left alone and not interfered with, the
White Dog will lie down just beneath where
its master’s body is hanging.
The dog never sleeps, nor does it require
any food or water, and does not even seem
to breathe.
And as long as Foundation research staff keep
their distance, both parts of SCP-1111 seem
content to remain in a docile state.
To keep them contained, the SCP Foundation
has established a two kilometer safe zone
around SCP-1111, keeping them monitored through
cameras attached to weather balloons.
The restricted enclosure is, according to
a public cover story, a weather monitoring
station, hence the balloons.
No member of Foundation staff is permitted
anywhere within a kilometer of SCP-1111, unless
they are given express permission from a superior
member of the Foundation.
Should SCP-1111-1 ever strays away from the
tree where its master hangs though, then the
area must be evacuated of all personnel until
the dog returns to its normal position.
However, Foundation staff are urged to be
wary when approaching SCP-1111, because the
White Dog may well be more ferociously loyal
than any pet.
Emphasis on ferocious.
The moment that 1111-1 becomes aware of anything
coming towards itself and its owner’s body,
the dog will become viciously hostile.
Regardless of the person or object coming
towards it, the semi-corporeal canine will
attempt to attack and destroy the intruder.
In this state, the White Dog exhibits even
more dramatic physiological differences from
a normal domesticated dog.
Video footage recorded by the SCP Foundation
shows that the dog is capable of reaching
incredible speeds of up to sixty kilometers
per hour, which is of course considerably
faster than an average canine.
The White Dog can also reach a height of six
meters when jumping up into the air, and has
teeth and a bite strength powerful enough
to tear through armor plating composed of
fifteen-millimeter-thick titanium.
Given the entity’s speed, aggression, and
translucent qualities, any attempts by the
SCP Foundation to neutralize the White Dog,
or even capture it for closer examination,
have ended the same grisly way for the staff
members who tried.
The creature’s fierce loyalty defending
its owner’s body also makes it incredibly
difficult for Foundation staff to even get
close enough to SCP-1111-2 to properly study
the remains.
As we said before, that “loyal” tag around
the dog’s neck is certainly an accurate
description.
On a date which has been redacted from its
file, an incident occurred involving SCP-1111
and a team that consisted of a number of Foundation
agents.
This team had been ordered to neutralize the
White Dog, and transport the anomalous animal
to a containment facility.
Attempting to evade the creature’s direct
line of sight, the agents approached the hanging
body of SCP-1111-2 from the North - the opposite
direction to the way the dog was facing.
Possessing a sense of hearing and smell far
beyond that of a human being, the White Dog
was able to quickly detect the agents approaching
its master.
When the team got within three hundred meters
of the tree where the body was hanging, the
canine set upon them, tearing at clothing
and shredding protective armor with its teeth
in order to get to the agents’ soft flesh
underneath.
One of these agents fled, running as fast
as they could from the area.
But, of course, this was a futile move, as
the White Dog quickly noticed and began to
pursue the Foundation agent with its super
powered speed.
As it chased them, surveillance cameras recorded
SCP-1111-1 decreasing in size, becoming harder
to see with the naked eye the further it ran
from the tree.
The dog’s speed began to decline too.
The further the dog got from the tree with
noose, the less the body hanging from it seemed
to be spasming too.
When the White Dog had reached 900 meters
from SCP-1111-2, the corpse was seen to stop
moving entirely, frozen and stiff, as one
would normally expect a deceased body to be.
Realizing how far away it was from its master,
SCP-1111-1 froze, appearing unsure for a moment.
It turned to look towards the body of its
master, perhaps sensing that the random jerks
and post-mortem movements had stopped.
At this point, the dog howled and sprinted
back towards the tree, causing the corpse
of its owner to begin twitching yet again.
Footage of this incident showed that the White
Dog was impervious to conventional weapons,
and any rounds fired at the canine by Foundation
agents merely passed through its ghostly body.
However, its claws and teeth were very much
solid, and it was able to slaughter almost
all the agents, save for the one who fled,
who ended up to be the sole survivor of the
encounter.
Following this disastrous mission, the O5
Council issued an order that, in order to
protect the lives of Foundation personnel,
only remote controlled drones and expendable
D-class personnel would be permitted anywhere
near SCP-1111.
Shortly after the previous incident, a group
of D-class were sent into the area around
the tree where SCP-1111-2 was hanging, this
time approaching from multiple directions
at once.
But this only led to the same results, as
the White Dog began to quickly move between
each of the D-classes, killing them one after
another.
Only one, D-83011, was able to make it close
enough to the corpse to make any noteworthy
observations.
As they approached, the hanging corpse of
SCP-1111-2 seemed to slow its jerks and twitches,
and the body did something that had never
been seen before, it opened its eyes.
It raised its arms towards the approaching
D-class in what looked like a welcoming hug,
only for D-83011 to be torn to shreds by the
White Dog moments after.
Cameras nearby picked up more previously unseen
movement, namely the owner’s mouth moving,
almost as if he was saying the words “no,
down boy.”
But soon after, the corpse fell limp again
and resumed its normal twitches.
Following this, the Foundation have theorized
that the White Dog could possibly be contained
by somehow removing its master’s body from
the area.
Some staff have also noted that SCP-1111 shares
certain traits with SCP-023, a similar anomalous
creature also referred to as The Black Shuck.
Much like the White Dog, the Shuck also possesses
a ghostly canine form and appears to be the
same large, dog-like creature that is referenced
in ancient folklore from throughout the British
Isles.
According to legends, the Shuck appears to
travelers at crossroads, serving as an omen
of bad luck, impending disaster, and is even
thought to be one of the hounds of Hell itself.
SCP-023, like SCP-1111, also has anomalous
abilities that focus on geographic space.
In the Black Shuck’s case, anyone it detects
approaching it will die or lose a member of
their family within a year.
Researchers working for the Foundation believed
that SCP-023 and SCP-1111-1 could be related,
or even instances of the same phenomenon,
a sort of dog yin and yang, but since they
have still, as of yet, been unable to capture
the White Dog, it has been impossible to verify
this.
The SCP Foundation will no doubt keep trying
though.
While testing may have been suspended for
the time being, they always know where to
find SCP-1111 - beneath its master’s hanged
body, guarding it, for all eternity.
Now go check out “SCP-1913 Deadly Monster
Squad - The Furies” and “SCP-2845 - Alien
God Crash Lands on Earth - THE DEER” for
more animal SCPs you have to see to believe!